that's a hard question I would I would
have to say in my case personally I you
know I don't think a lot about this I
have to say but I'm quite sure that
there is that you know Fred was an
incredible observer he was he was he was
very very good observer and he could and
what he wrote about what the clinical
phenomenon were very insightful and and
also you know things like his ideas
about the concept of transference how
people basically think you know bring to
a new relationship the expectations and
predictions they have from other gleaned
from other earlier relationships
especially attachment relationships you
know I that's my background and I'm sure
it still informs what I do
okay yes
think I absolutely think and very much
hope but I mean I think it's an
essential part of of healing people and
when we know this regardless of what
other ways we develop and you know
whether they be neurobiological methods
and now we're talking not only about
psychopharmacology but a lot of other
kinds of brain stimulation for example
and and even some kinds of very focused
neuro surgery seem to be you know things
that have promised for certain people in
certain situations so I do very much see
psychiatry developing in the direction
of neuroscience and neurobiology I think
we've we've made some great leaps in
that direction and and I think we will
and we should continue to work in that
in that area at the same time you know
one of the things about psychotherapy
zs-- is that the more you know the more
focused psycho therapies actually are
better able to target specific
behavioral syndromes than any kind of
somatic treatment that we have so far so
I definitely think that there's a role
for you know for very focused kind of
technical interpersonal interventions
that are you know so to say
psychological interventions I don't
think that will ever go away but I I
think we we're learning more and more
about those kinds of interventions and
again specific techniques like there's a
very interesting there's a very
interesting recent report of using
training and attention in attentional
processes in in some anxiety disorders
in social phobia in generalized anxiety
probably for any of the anxieties and
anxiety disorders because one of the
things that you do when you have an
anxiety disorder is you over focus on
certain kinds of cues like we were
talking about with panic you know if
you're a social ly anxious person you're
going to do that with social cues you're
going to be overly sensitive to social
cues and you can train people apparently
away from that by training their
attention
and so that's one kind of thing I see
happening in the future but you know but
for many of I would say virtually all of
the conditions we treat there's always
going to be some way in which the person
who has the problem will need to to kind
of get close to really close to very
distressing emotions and thoughts and to
do that I think you really need to feel
safe and to feel safe in any treatment
you need another person you know you
need a person who can can be there for
you so you know I think that will always
be there